( intro music )
( applause )
Ken Edgett: I've been with
this project with the Rover
since 2004
when we proposed the cameras
that take all these
beautiful color images.
And... but my own story
goes back to
reading National Geographic
in the early 1970s,
and the coverage
of the Mariner missions
and the Voyager and Apollo.
So, it's kinda trippy
to be standing here right now.
This is a landscape.
Mount Sharp you see
to the upper left
rising out of the scene
in that direction...
in the other direction,
you don't actually
see it here, but we'll see it.
You'll see the wall of Gale,
off further in the distance.
Mount Sharp is three miles high
of layered sediment.
The kinds of outcrops of rock
that we've been looking at
since we landed are more like
ankle and knee high.
And some of them
are down underfoot like
the mudstone that we drill.
By the way,
two years ago when we landed,
if you said the first thing
we drilled
was going to be a mudstone.
And that,
we would find that it was
actually
habitable environment,
I wouldn't have believed you.
So, this has been
an amazing two years.
You see, Curiosity carries
its name on its arm,
it carries its name
on its sleeve.
And... what we are doing,
we are geologists
for the most part,
and what we are doing is,
trying to read the history
of this place
in the layered rock.
We call it stratigraphy.
So basically, the oldest rocks
are at the bottom of the stack
and the youngest
are at the top,
and so, if you go like,
to the Grand Canyon
in Arizona,
for example or Letchworth,
I've been there many times.
Older... younger.
So, what you see
here behind me is one of these
landscapes in a place
called Dingo Gap.
This was just
a few months ago.
In the far distance
you actually see
the north wall of Gale Crater.
So, we are trying to look
at these rocks
with the rover and trying to
understand the history
that they are telling us
about this place.
Here's another place
we call this one Shaler
and this is layered rocks,
laid down by moving water
in a stream.
All of that orange-brown stuff
you see,
that's the dust.
The rocks is
the dark grey stuff.
Everything we've seen in Gale
has been sedimentary rock
and it's been
various shades of grey.
Here's another landscape again
in the direction
we are driving.
Here you can actually see
the wall of Gale off
in the far distance
and you see a little bit of
Mount Sharp off
in this corner up here,
in front of us,
right in the foreground
is a little drift of sand...
windblown sand.
What we've been dealing
with here is
a very, very thin veneer of
windblown sand,
windblown dust,
and all those little pebbles
and cobbles you see,
that's just the detritus,
as this rock breaks down
and then wind carries it away.
This is a story of...
we are right there
by the bed rock,
it is right under our feet,
we can drive up to it,
we can read this history,
but we do have to deal with
this veneer of dust and sand,
and pebbles here and there.
Wind erosion
is a big deal in Gale
in allowing us
to do our jobs.
And if you look in the sort of
the bottom middle
of this picture,
you see a little pebble
and behind it is a protrusion
going back under the sand
into the rock outcrop,
or into the rock face.
The little pebble
and then this protrusion.
That pebble protected
all that rock behind it
as wind blew sand
and eroded that rock back
except where that pebble was.
That's like one of
my favorite pictures
from this mission.
Now, here is a close up.
Like I said sedimentary rock,
so this is bits of old rock.
So, think about
the history here.
There was rock on Mars.
That rock broke apart,
made sand and pebbles
and cobbles and dust.
And then, that stuff was
transported by wind or water
and deposited in Gale.
And then later,
it becomes rock,
okay, so sediment then
becomes rock
and then even later
the wind is eroding that,
leaving like that protrusion
with the pebble. Okay.
This is a picture of one of
the conglomerates that we saw.
This is a close up
and you see a penny for scale,
so you get some idea...
these are actually
very small pebbles,
something about
the size of Lincoln's head...
that penny is also on Mars,
but not actually
in this photo,
I photoshopped that in.
To give you a sense of scale,
but that-- the rover carries
that penny with it
and I love to use it
for scale,
because we are all
familiar with that.
That was a Conglomerate.
Now I'm going to go to
a finer grain sediment,
this is a sandstone. Okay?
And what you are looking at
is the sand is both,
the very dark grey mass
that you see everywhere.
You can't actually see
the individual grains
because they are actually
smaller than
the camera was resolving here.
And then you see
little protrusions
which are larger sand grains
set in that finer sand.
Those protrusions are there
because of wind erosion,
those are resisting
the blasting by the sand,
so they stick out.
But then at the bottom
you see a void,
you see out of focus
dirt in the background...
because this is a layer,
it's forming a shelf overhang
and the layer beneath it
retreated back out of view,
you can't see it.
Now, everything
you see in this picture
that looks kind of brownish
or reddish
is just dust
sitting on the rock.
This rock is dark grey.
Next slide shows
the finest grain
sedimentary rock we've seen
which is this mudstone
and the penny here
is for scale again
and you see an area
that the rover brushed,
it has a little wire brush.
We don't use it often,
but when we do it,
it does a good job.
Now, let's look at that
close up. Okay?
The camera on the arm
can get right down
literally within an inch or so
and we can take these
close up views.
Here now,
you actually see grooves cut
into the rock by the brush.
So, this rock is not
really, really hard,
it actually can get
little grooves from the wire,
as it, the wire brush
as it moves.
And you see some of the dust
that is sort of generated
as it swirls that up.
But when we look
at the rock itself,
ignore the dust,
ignore the groove,
we find that the grains
are too small
to see... with this camera.
And this is one of highest
resolution images
ever taken outside
of a microscope,
you know, on board
the Phoenix Lander,
this is one of the highest,
right down there
with this camera
and we can't see the grains.
So, they are
very, very fine grains.
So, let me talk briefly about
some of the other tools.
You've seen a lot of pictures.
You get a sense that
we can do a lot with pictures.
But we also want to know about
the chemistry of the rocks
and the minerals
that make up the rocks.
This is the arm, it's that
the white thing sticking down
and then the turret
and the shadow underneath it,
you see a little box,
called the APXS.
That is a science instrument
that is using X-rays and
it is measuring the chemistry
of the rock there.
So, that is one of our tools.
Here now is
another brushed spot.
This was just
at the end of April.
This was a sandstone...
and remember the penny
in the brushed spot.
So, it is like three, or
four, five pennies across,
but you see an array of dots
going through that,
those were formed
by a laser beam,
zapping the rock
at each one of those spots.
Multiple times,
at each spot... okay?
And then the instrument
observes
the light
that comes off of that
as it zaps it and it can
tell you something about
the chemistry of the rock
that way.
Later in May,
we actually drilled this rock.
But here is
our very first drill hole.
The diameter is
16 millimeters.
One-six millimeters, I don't
know what is a millimeter.
Well, a Roosevelt dime,
a US dime is 17 millimeters.
So, this is one millimeter
smaller than a dime.
This is the stuff
that if you told me
this was going to be
first thing we drilled,
you know, before we landed,
I didn't even know that
we would land, right?
It... it... ( laughter )
You see
the grey mudstone there,
you also see this
white lightning bolt.
That is... there was a crack
in that rock
at some point in its history
and minerals filled that...
sulphur and calcium
bearing minerals
filled that vein.
Getting a picture like this
allows us
to get a sense of what did
we actually drill through.
Then that sample
is put into instruments
that are inside
the rover's body.
One to find out
what the minerals are
and one to find out
what the chemistry is.
I just want to leave you
with this
because
this is why we do this.
It's really for
understanding our home and
so what you are seeing is
the rim of Gale after sunset,
and there's a bright dot
in the sky. That's Earth.
And if you look up
at the little blow up,
you actually see
there are two dots.
The bright one is Earth,
the fainter one is the moon.
You can see these from Mars.
And we study this stuff
to understand our home planet.
Just as much,
because of our curiosity.
Thank you.
( applause )
( outro music )